اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من مدينه نابلس اهلا
بكم جيش الاحتلال يعلن مقتل ضابط واصابه
21 عسكريا في معارك قطاع غزه خلال الساعات
ال 24 الماضيه ويعزز قواته في خان يونس
بلواء سابع وابو عبيده يؤكد في تسجيل حصلت
عليه الجزيره ان لا صفقات قبل وقف العدوان
ويعلن تدمير
825 اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه منذ بدء الحرب
وكتائب القسام تقول انها فجرت حقل الغام
في قوه اسرائيليه بمخيم البريج واوقعت
افرادها بين قتيل
وجريح نحو 60 شهيدا وعشرات المفقودين في
قصف اسرائيلي على مخيمي النصيرات والمغازي
وسط القطاع وفي رفح جنوبا واستشهاد 45
فلسطينيا في قصف اسرائيل
على مدينه غزه ووزاره الصحه في غزه تعلن
ارتفاع عدد ضحايا القصف الاسرائيلي الى
187 شهيدا خلال الساعات ال 24
الماضيه الاونور وتؤكد اطلاق جنود
اسرائيليين النار على قافله مساعدات اثناء
عودتها من شمال قطاع غزه على طريق محدده
جيش الاحتلال ووكيل الامين العام للامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه يقول ان ايصال
المساعدات لسكان غزه اصبح مستحيلا ويدعو
لوقف اطلاق
النار اصابه اربعه جنود اسرائيليين في
عمليه دهس في الخليل جنوبي الضفه الغربيه
واستشهاد المنفذ والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
تسقط طائره مسيره للاحتلال في مخيم
الفارعه بطوباس وتعطي اليه بعبوه ناسفه
وسط اشتباكات بعد اقتحام قوات خاصه
اسرائيليه للمخيم الى
اللقاء